so it's michael and michelle
just when you thought that vaccines
couldn't be given out much quicker in
the uk
parts of greater manchester have invited
everyone
over the age of 18.
so all day at rochdale football club
they rolled in
for the roll out well i i did get a
phone call to
um get an appointment in a few weeks but
i just thought i'd come beforehand
anyway just
just because i wanted it it's just a
step forward isn't it yeah
she can't wait to get to get back to
normal i'd feel more bad
giving it someone else than having it
myself if i had it myself i'm like okay
but if you pass it on someone
you have to be registered at a rochdale
gp but that was the only condition
of joining the queue partly it may be
the fear
that the indian variant it's very uh
contagious
the impact of getting a corvid infection
for some it may be that now that the
road map is kicking in
they want to go on holiday now that the
pubs and clubs and other things are
opening up and the gyms are opening up
up to now 18 and above they've not been
given a chance
to get the vaccine i'm not that bad
that's one of the most painful vaccines
i've ever had
this is only happening in a few select
areas and here in rochdale it's about
seeing what's gone on
down the road in bolton or blackburn and
realizing
they just can't afford to wait for the
national rollout
the national rollout has now delivered
50 million doses
it's meant hospitality is enjoying its
first weekend back
indoors it was even a wedding on
at the medicine tap in rochdale their
first
in two years it's been a long
i mean we've not had a wedding like this
on for about a couple of years now so
it's it's been good and we had we had
someone in this morning dressed in the
room getting that back again arranging
seating plans
going over menus going over drinks
packages it's been brilliant
it's been really good the indian variant
is though still growing in some areas
and now a yorkshire variant is also
being monitored
but now that so many vaccines have been
given out the government strategy
is evolving we are over time carefully
shifting the responsibility towards more
personal responsibility
all of us know what's what's safer
outdoors is safer
if you've been vaccinated it's safer and
making sure that you keep your distance
where you can and so that personal
responsibility is on
all of us to try to keep this under
control whilst we get the vaccine
through the whole population
surge testing is also being deployed in
more parts of london now
tackling outbreaks or finding new
variants
will be part of our lives for the
foreseeable future
tom parmenter sky news rochdale